ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่แอดตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนหน้าสวัสดีครับ
ว้าววันนี้กลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยนะกลับกลัว
แต่พี่อาตี้แล้วก็น้องเรียมกันนะครับใช่
คะวันนี้เรามาเรียนการวันนี้วันที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับที่เรามาเจอกันวันนี้ครับวันนี้
วันที่ 25 ค่ะหน้าวันนี้วันที่ 25  OO
วันที่ 25 เป็นวันอะไรครับเป็นวันจันทร์
ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์ที่ 25 เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนตุลาคมเดือนนี้เป็นเดือน
ตุลาคมนะครับ 5 ปีปีคริสตศักราชอะไรเอ่ย
อีกคลิปจะสักกะ
2021  5 ปีคริสต์ศักราชหรือคศ 2000  21
นั่นเองนะครับผชอะไรครับเมื่อปีพศ
2564 ใช่ครับปีนี้ปีพศ
2564 ว้าว 5 แล้วตอนนี้ครับตอนนี้ที่เรา
กำลังคุยกันอยู่ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับ
กี่โมงแรง
07:23 ค่ะอ๋อ
7:00 น
23 นาทีใช่ไหมน้าโอเคเอ็ดโมงยี่สิบสาม
นาทีเป็นเจ็ดโมงเช้านะครับ 5 ตอนนี้ยัง
อยู่ 5 เช้าๆเรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันว้าวนะ
ครับหน้าวันนี้
พี่กับน้องเรียมมีเรื่องจะมาเล่าให้นัก
เรียนฝั่งหน้าเป็นเรื่องราวสนุกๆของเด็ก
ผู้หญิงคนหนึ่ง
หญิงคนนึงให้
โอ้นี่คนนี้เลย
แล้วก็นักเรียนรู้จักไหมคะ
เด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้รู้จักไหม
อ้าวเด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้ชื่ออะไรครับน้อง
เรียม
เด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้ชื่อหนูน้อยหมวกแดงอ๋อ
อ๋อหนูน้อยหมวกแดงโอ้ชื่อยาวจังเลยชื่อ
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงทำไมทำไมถึงชื่อหนูน้อย
หมวกแดงครับหนูน้อยเพราะว่าเขาเป็นเด็ก
ตัวเล็กขอเป็นเด็กตัวเล็กให้เด็กตัวเล็กๆ
เอาก็เรียกว่าหนูน้อย
หนูน้อย
หนูน้อยใส่หมวกอ๋ออ๋อนี่
หมายนี่ใส่หมวกแต่หน้าเป็นหมวกสีแดงอ๋อก็
เลยชื่อว่าหนูน้อยหมวกแดง
น่ารักจังเลยหนูน้อยหมวกเสื้อพี่อ่ะพี่
เลยค่ะฮ่าๆๆเดียววันนี้พี่เอ็ดดี้ก็ใส่
เสื้อสีแดงเหมือนกันน่ะเรียนก็จะพี่ไม่
ได้เป็นหนูน้อย
ไม่ใช่หนูน้อยโอเค
ปาร์ตี้เสื้อแดงแดง
เรียงมีต้องกาหมอมีปากกาสีแดงห้าสีแดง
ตะเข้อ่าเมื่อกี้นี้ครับหนูน้อยหมวกแดง
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงทำอะไรอยู่ครับเนี่ยหนู
น้อยหมวกแดงกำลังหาเดิมนางอ่าเดินโอ้
กำลังเดินอยู่ไหนหมวกแดงถืออะไรมาด้วย
ครับหนูน้อยหมวกแดงมือถือเนอะคืออะไรบ้าง
อ๋ออ๋อถึงจะกล้ามา
ถือตะกร้าตะกร้าเอาไว้ทำอะไรครับจะกล้า
เอาไว้ใส่ของอ๋อแต่กล้าเอาไว้ใส่ของใน
ตะกร้าของหนูน้อยหมวกแดงมีอะไรอยู่ตรงนี้
ครับใส่อะไรมาครับใส่ขนมปังค่ะอ๋อว้าวใส่
ขนมปังมาขุน
เหมือนน้อยหมวกแดงถือตะกร้าใช่แล้วก็ใส่
ขนมปังมาโอ้ขนมปังของน้องเลียมันใหญ่มาก
ใหญ่
โอ้น่ากินจังเลยโอเคหนูน้อยหมวกแดงถือ
ตะกร้าใส่ขนมปังจะไปไหนครับเนี่ย
กลับไปหาคุณยายอ๋อจะเดินไปหาคุณยายอ้าไป
คุณยายทำไมครับ
เขาว่าคุณยายไม่สบาย
คุณยายไม่สบายคุณยายหน้าแก่แล้วคุณยายไม่
สบายวันนี้หนูน้อยหมวกแดงกำลังจะเดินไปหา
คุณยายเอาขนมปังเอาขนมปังไปให้คุณยายใช่
ไหมใครเปลี่ยนตังค์ไปให้คุณยายอ้าโอเคอ่ะ
นอกจากในรูปนี้จะมีหนูน้อยหมวกแดงแล้ว
เบียร์ที่ยังเห็นยังเห็นอย่างอื่นอีกหลาย
ๆอย่างในรูปนี้เลยมีอะไรอีกบ้างครับในรูป
นี้มีสัตว์ป่าเยอะเลยค่ะอีสัตว์ป่าว้าวมี
แต่ป่าเยอะเลยมีอะไรบ้างครับนักเรียนรู้
จักอะไรในรูปนี้บ้างครับน้าตัวแรกตัวแรก
ที่ที่น้องเรียมจะอ่าอ่ะหน้าตาสอนนัก
เรียนน่ะเป็นตัวที่ใหญ่ที่สุดในรูปนี้ใส่
มาใหม่ตีไก่มากในรูปนี้ครับน่าอยู่ด่าค่ะ
อ๋ออ๋อหมาป่าป่านี่ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะหมาป่า
อยู่ตรงนี้นี่หมาป่าวหมาป่าตัวใหญ่น่า
กลัวน่ารวนก็ก็หมาป่าหมาป่ากำลังทำอะไร
อยู่ครับตอนนี้มาป่ากำลังจ้องไปที่หนู
น้อยหมวกแดงอ๋ออ๋อกำลังจ้องไปที่หนูน้อย
หมวกแดงนะครับอ่ากำลังมองมาที่หนูน้อย
หมวกแดงว้าวท่าทางน่ากลัวจริงๆๆนอกจากมี
หมาป่าแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับในป่ากระรอก
ในป่านี้มีกระรอกด้วยกระรอกอยู่ตรงไหน
อยู่ตรงไหนต้นดอกไม้มีกระรอกอยู่ตรงนี้ 1
ตัวแล้วมีกระรอกอีกไหมครับมีอีก 1 ตัว
หรือตัวนี้นี่กระรอกอยู่ตรงนี้มีกระรอก 2
ตัวอยู่บนต้นไม้
โว้โอทั้งคู่เลยอ้อเฮียตี้ยังเห็นยังเห็น
นี่
พี่นิกรอรอกหรือเปล่าครับใช่กะรอบค่ะอ๋อ
อ๋อไม่ใช่กับก็นี้ตัวอะไรครับนกอ๋ออ๋อนี่
มีนกอยู่ 5 มีนกอยู่บนต้นไม้อยู่บนต้นไม้
เหมือนกระรอกเลยกระรอกก็อยู่บนต้นไม้เออ
หน้ามีกระรอก 2 ตัวมีนก 2 ตัวเหมือนกัน
เน๊อะโอเคแล้วก็มีผีเสื้อนะค่ะตัวนี้นี่
ผีเสื้อด้วยหรอผีเสื้ออยู่ตรงไหนครับอยู่
ในอยู่
ผีเสื้อบินอยู่
ผีเสื้อบินผีเสื้อนี่กำลังบิลอยู่ผีเสื้อ
บินตามหนูน้อยหมวกแดงมานี่นี่ค่ะแล้วมี
ผิดวัว
วิธีเสื้อ 1 ตัว
สิริผีเสื้ออยู่อ๋ออ๋อใช่หนูน้อยหมวกแดง
ก็มองผีเสื้ออ่าโอเคน้อยหมวกแดงมองอีก
เหมือนที่หมาป่าหมาป่าก็มองมองหนูน้อย
หมวกแดงเหมือนกันใช่มะอ๋อ
โอเคเดี๋ยวเรารีบไปหาคุณยายดีกว่าคุณยาย
รอหนูน้อยหมวกแดงอยู่นะครับ
[เพลง]
5555 รอหนูน้อยหมวกก็แพงอยู่ ka แล้วก็
อันนี้ก็อ่อนที่จะไปหาคุณยายหมาป่าเดิน
ออกมาเดินออกมาคุยกับหนูน้อยหมวกแดงนะอ่า
ทำไมหมาป่าถึงออกมาคุยกับหนูน้อยหมวกแดง
ครับ
หมาป่า
มาขอขนมปังอ๋ออ๋อป่าอยากกินขนมปังเพราะ
ว่าหนูน้อยหมวกแดงมีขนมปังอยู่ในตัดว่า
อะแล้วหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็แบ่งขนมปังใช่ไหม
นี่หนูน้อยหมวกแดงกำลังหยิบกำลังหยิบขนม
ปังออกมาจากตะกร้าหน้า
แล้วแล้วก็แบ่ง 5 แบ่งขนมปังให้หมาป่า
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงใจดี jai  D  EE หน้าแบ่ง
ขนมปังให้หมาป่าคู่มือแล้วมาป่าตอนนี้หมา
ป่ากำลังทำอะไรครับกำลังกินขนมปังนั่งกิน
ขนมปังอยู่ตอนนี้เออ
เต้ามาป่าวเอาเจ้ามาปาดตัวใหญ่ตัวสูงมาก
เลยใช่ไหมครับตัวสูงกว่าหนูน้อยหมวกแดง
อ่ะหมาป่าตัวสูงกว่ามากเลยโหหน้าแต่เจ้า
มาปากกินขนมปังกินขนมปังแล้วยังไม่อิ่ม
ใช่ไหมยังไม่อิ่ม 5 ม็อบไปแล้วกินไปแล้ว
ชิ้นนึง
เหลือยัง
มาป่าอยากกินอีกแต่หนูน้อยหมวกแดง
ไม่ให้แล้วอ่ะให้ไม่ได้เพราะว่าจะเอาไป
ให้ไปให้ใครครับใครเขาก็จะเอาขนมปังนี้ไป
ให้คุณยาย
ไอ้ห่า
โหถ้าอย่างงั้นหมาป่าคิดในใจคิดคิดคิดๆ
น่าคิดว่าจะทำยังไงถึงจะได้กินขนมปังอีก
มาป่าอยากกินขนมปังอีก
มาก
อาทิมาป่าทำยังไงครับ
น้าวิ่ง
อ้าครับมาป่าก็เลยวิ่งไปวิ่งไปอยู่ที่ไหน
ครับ
ที่บ้านของคุณยายอ้อหมาป่าก็วิ่งไปรอที่
บ้านของคุณยายแล้วมาปากก็ไปเจอกับคุณยาย
โอ้คุณยายอกใจใช่ไหมตกใจเลยโอ้วหมาป่าหมา
ป่ามาทำอะไรเออเสร็จแล้วหมาป่าก็คิดว่า
พ่อต้องรีบ
หน้าตัดการคุณยายนะเพื่อที่คะเดี๋ยวหนู
น้อยหมวกแดงมาหมาป่าจะได้กินขนมที่หนู
น้อยหมวกแดงแล้วป้าทำอะไรกับคุณยายคะโอ้
หมาป่าก็เลยกินคุณยายเข้าป่าว
หมาป่ายิ่ง
กินคุณยายเข้าไปในท้องหมาป่าโหน่ากลัวไหม
ครับหมาป่านาคๆมาป่านนอกจากกินขนมแล้วกิน
คุณยายด้วย
ภาษาอังกฤษเยอะมากๆๆกินเยอะมากเพราะหมา
ป่ากินคุณยายเสร็จแล้วหน้าแล้วมาป่าก็น่า
ทำยังไงต่อครับหมาป่าก็ขึ้นไปนอนนอนนอน
อยู่บนเตียงของคุณยายนั้นนอนรอรอหนูน้อย
หมวกแดงหน้า
ออกมาแล้วตอนนี้ครับนี่หนูน้อยหมวกแดงมา
ถึงบ้านคุณยายแล้วครับโห 5 หมาป่าหน้าตอน
นี้หนูน้อยหมวกแดงเดินมาถึงบ้านคุณยาย
แล้วนะคะฮ่าๆเดินมาถึงบ้านคุณยายแล้วนี่
หมาป่ามามาอยู่ที่ไหนครับตอนนี้หมาป่า
อยู่บนเตียงนอนอ่านี่มาป่าอยู่บนเตียงนอน
ของคุณยายมีครับอ๊าหมาป่านอนอยู่บนเตียง
นอนของคุณยายใช่ครับเตียงนอนมีผ้าห่มม้า
ป่านอนห่มผ้าอยู่บนเตียงแต่ตอนนี้หนูน้อย
หมวกแดงหนูน้อยหมวกแดงรู้ไหมครับวันนี้
คุณยายหรือว่านี่หมาป่า
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงไม่รู้ไม่รู้หนูน้อยหมวก
แดงไม่เธอรู้ใช่ไหมครับทำไมถึงไม่รู้ครับ
มองไม่เห็นอ๋อเพราะตอนนี้มองไม่เห็นมัน
มืดในห้องนี้มืดใช่ไหมครับอ่าในห้องมีมืด
เพราะว่าไม่ได้เปิดไฟอ่ะไม่ได้เปิดไฟก็
เลย
หน้าก็เลยมองไม่มีเทียนมีตะเกียงแต่ไม่
ได้จบตรงนี้มีตะเกียงเพราะว่าตอนนี้คุณ
ยายนอนอยู่คุณยายก็เลยไม่ได้จุดเทียนนี้
ครับเทียนอยู่ตรงนี้มีตะเกียงอยู่ตรงนี้
ก็ไม่ได้จุดน่ะหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็เลยมองไม่
เห็นมองไม่เห็นว่านี่เป็นหมาป่าหรือว่า
เป็นคุณยาย
หน้าจากนั้นนะฮะเมื่อหมาป่าเห็นหนูน้อย
หมวกแดงเดินเข้ามาม้าป่าเห็นหนูน้อยหมวก
แดงเดินเข้ามามาปากทำให้ครับ
มาด้วยความน้องหมาป่าหิวตอนนี้กำลังหิว
มากล่ะป่าก็เลยกินขนมหน้าที่อ้ากินของพี่
หนูน้อยแกถือมาแต่กินขนมไปแล้วมาปากก็ยัง
หิวอยู่ยังไม่อิ่ม
เห้ยยังไม่อิ่มหน้าพอมาปากกินขนมหมดแล้ว
แต่ยังไม่อิ่มก็เลยที่นิก็เลยกินหนูน้อย
หมวกแดงเข้าไปด้วย
โอ้ยมาฝากกินเยอะจังเลย
น่ากินเยอะ
หมาป่ากินอะไรเข้าไปบ้าง
หมาป่ากิน
คุณยาย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
คุณยายด้วยอ่ะเออแล้วก็ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ก็กิน
หนูน้อยหมู่ที่ o  o  o กินเยอะมากเลยนัก
เรียนนักเรียนกินเยอะเหมือนหมาป่าไว้ครับ
ไม่ใช่มากินใบเยอะอ่าอ้ากินมีเกี่ยว they
are
แล้วเมื่อหมาป่ากินคุณยายกินหนูน้อยหมวก
แดงเข้าไปนะครับในระหว่างนั้นหน้าหมาป่า
ก็อ่านอนหลับไปหาเมื่อกี้กิน
5 หลายอย่างหมาป่าก็ท้องท้องเป็นไงครับ
ขอใหญ่ใหญ่มากเลยตอนนี้ 5 ตอน
ตัดยุ้ยเลยโอเค
หน้าหมาป่าก็ท้องใหญ่มากเลยอ่า
อะไรครับตอนนี้นอนอยู่นอนหลับไปเพราะว่า
อิ่มอิ่มมาคะแล้วก็นอนหลับไปหน้าตอนที่
หมาป่ากำลังนอนหลับอยู่ครับมีคนตัดไม้
หน้ามีคนตัดไม้มาเคาะประตูพร้อมประตูป๊อก
คุณยายคุณยายอยู่ไหมครับน้า
ใหญ่ไม่ตอบ 5 คุณยายไม่ตอบเพราะว่าอะไร
ครับยาอยู่ในท้องหมาป้าคุณยายอยู่ในท้อง
ของหมาป่าในครับดังนั้นคนตัดไม้ก็เลยเปิด
ประตูเปิดประตูหาใช่ครับนี่คนตัดไม้ก็เลย
เปิดประตูออกเปิดประตูแล้วเดินเข้ามาใน
บ้าน
ห่าเปิดประตูกวางเปิดประตูกว้างแล้วเดิน
เข้ามาในบ้านใช่ครับเวลาเปิดประตูบ้านก็
จะมีแสงสว่างเข้ามาน้ามีคนตัดไม้ก็เลย
เห็นเห็นอะไรครับตอนนี้คุณจะมาเห็นอะไร
หมาป่า
ชายคนตัดไม้เห็นหมาป่าหมาป่ากำลังนอนนอน
หลับอาจนอนหลับอยู่บนเตียงโว้คนตัดไม้
เห็นแล้วคุณจะไม้หน้าเป็นไงครับ
ตกใจออกใจคนตัดไม้ตกใจอ่ะทำไมต้องหมาป่า
มันนอนอยู่บนเตียงของคุณยายเออแล้วก็จาก
นั้นคนตัดไม้ก็ได้ยินได้ยินเสียงคุณยาย
ได้ยินเสียงคุณยายเรียกออกมาจากในท้อง 5
คุณยายตะกอนบอกคนตัดไม้ว่าช่วยด้วยช่วย
ด้วยอยู่ในท้องนาๆๆคนตัดไม้ได้ยินดังนั้น
คนตัดไม้ก็เลยอ่ะก็ดีและก็เลยใช้ขวานนี่
ควรจะหมายถึงขวานมาถือขวานมาด้วยนะใช่
ครับๆเดี๋ยวน้องเรียมวาดรูปขวานให้นัก
เรียนดูหน่อยอ่ะขวาน
ขวัญจะเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะๆคนตัดไม้ใช้ขวานผ่า
ท้องพาท้องหมาป่า
ชายผ่าท้องหมาป่าหน้าแล้วก็ช่วยคุณยายออก
มาจากของของหมาป่าช่วยคุณยายน่ะแล้วก็
ช่วยหนูน้อยหมวกแดงด้วยเนอะออกมาจากท้อง
ของหมาป่า
[เพลง]
5 แล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้ต้องมาปากเป็นยังไงมา
ป่าวก็ยังนอน
[เพลง]
ไม่รู้เรื่องเลยว่าตอนนี้คุณยายกับหนู
น้อยหมวกแดงออกมาจากท้องของเจ้าหมาป่า
แล้วเอาหน่าจากนั้นครับเมื่อคุณยายกับหนู
น้อยหมวกแดงออกมาจากท้องหมาป่าแล้วคุณยาย
เห็นเจ้าหมาป่ากำลังนอนหมดแรงอยู่นะครับ
แล้วทำไมนิติ
คุณยายเลยช่วยกันช่วยกันใช้เข็มอ่ะเย็บ
ท้องของมาป่าเพราะว่าเมื่อกี้นี้คนตัดไม้
ใช้มีดใช้ขวานผ่าท้องผ่าท้องเพื่อให้คุณ
ยายออกมาจากท้องของหมาป่าใช่ไหมค่ะนี่ก็
เลยต้องเย็บเย็บเย็บเข้าไปอ่ะเอาเข็มเข็ม
แบบใช้เขต
ได้เย็บท้องของเจ้าหมาป่านะครับอ่านี่
เป็นท้องยายก็เย็บเย็บเย็บอาเย็บคืนเข้า
ไปหาฮ่าๆๆ
กลัวไหมน้องเรียมกลัวถ้าเราไม่ครับมหาป่า
ไม่เจ็บเหรอคะโอ๊ยปณป่าไม่รู้เรื่องหรือ
เปล่านอนหลับอยู่
ๆแล้วหลังจากนั้นหลังจากนั้นนะครับอ่า
เมื่อเย็บท้องเสร็จแล้วนะครับคุณยายก็
ปลุกก็มาปากขึ้นมานี่เจ้ามาป่าเจ้าลุก
ขึ้นไปจัดเตียงของคุณยายได้แล้วตอนนี้น้า
มะป่าก็ตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วตกใจตกใจที่เจอคน
ตัดไม้อยู่อ่ะอ่าเจ้าหมาป่าตกใจดังนั้นก็
เลยลุกขึ้นแล้ววิ่งหนีออกจากบ้านไปครับ
น่าจะเข้ามาป่าววิ่งเร็วได้ไหมครับไม่ได้
วิ่งเร็ว
ๆเพราะว่าตอนนี้เจ็บท้องมีพระคุณยายเย็บ
ท้องไว้ให้นะครับหน้าว้าวต้องมาปากก็เลย
เดินเจ็บ
แต่ของน่าเดินร้องโอ๊ะโอ๊ะโอ๊ยโอ๊ย
เจ็บนะน้าแล้วก็วิ่งหนีเข้าป่าไป
มีอะไรอยู่ในท้องหมาป่าวไหมคะอ๋อโอเคนี่
ในท้องหมาป่ามีอะไรใช่ไหมครับอ่าตอนที่
วันที่คุณยายหน้าตอนที่คุณยายเย็บท้อง
เนี่ยก่อนที่จะเย็บท้องเนี่ยคนตัดไม้ก็
เอาก้อนหินก้อนหินใส่เข้าไปในท้องเจ้าหมา
ป่า 5 เพื่อที่เพื่อที่ให้เจ้าหมาป่าจะ
ได้ไม่มากินคนอื่นอีกจะได้ไม่กลับมากิน
คุณยายจะได้ไม่กลับมากินหนูน้อยหมวกแดง
อีก 5 คนตัดไม้ก็เลยทำโทษเจ้าหมาป่าด้วย
การเอาตอนหินก้อนหินนี่นี่ก็เห็นพรุ่งนี้
ใส่ก็ไปในท้องเจ้าหมาป่าแงะนี้ก็เย็บกลับ
คืนไปอา
ตาๆเจ้ามาปากก็เลยเจ็บท้องมากๆตอนนี้แล้ว
ก็เดินร้องโอยเจ็บท้องหน้าแล้วก็เดินกลับ
เข้าป่าไปก็
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็เลยรอดกลับมาได้คุณยายก็
เลยรอดกลับมาได้อ่ะตอนนี้
แล้วเรื่องเด็กในต่อคะเพื่อตี้ต่อมาต่อมา
คนตัดไม้ก็พาหนูน้อยหมวกแดงกลับมาบ้าน
หน้ากลับมาที่บ้าน
บ้านของหนูน้อยหมวกแดงนะที่บ้านของน้อย
หมวกแดงมีใครอยู่ครับมีคนหา
คุณแม่อ่าคุณแม่รอหนูน้อยหมวกแดงอยู่ที่
บ้านนะครับใช่ค่ะเขาคอยกอดภัย
แต่ตอนนี้ทุกคนปลอดภัยดีครับสามารถคุณยาย
ก็ปลอดภัยหนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็ปลอดภัยนาแล้ว
หนูน้อยหมวกแดงก็ขอบคุณคนตัดไม้ที่มาช่วย
เออขอบคุณที่มาช่วยหนูน้อยหมวกแดงแล้วก็
ช่วยคุณยายด้วยนะครับอ่าแล้วคุณแม่คุณแม่
ก็ขอบคุณคนตัดไม้ที่พาหนูน้อยหมวกแดงกลับ
มาที่บ้านชายค่ะหนูน้อยลงแดงก็จะพูดกับคน
ตัดไม้ว่าขอบคุณค่ะๆขอบคุณนะขอบคุณเวลา
ที่มีคนมาทำช่วยเหลือเราเราก็จะขอบคุณคน
ที่มาช่วยเรา
ขอบคุณโอเคและนี่คือเรื่องราวของหนูน้อย
หมวกแดงในวันนี้นะครับน้านักเรียนหน้านัก
เรียนสนุกไหมครับกับเรื่องที่มันเล่าให้
ฟังก็วันนี้สนุกไหมคะสนุกไหมครับเรียนรู้
สึกสงสาร
สงสารตาป่าทราย
คนที่ทำไม่ดีก็จะต้องได้รับโทษนะก็น่า
สงสารเพราะฉะนั้นเราต้องไม่ทำสิ่งที่ไม่
ดีให้กับคนอื่นทรายมีหรือแค่แล้วเดี๋ยว
คราวหน้านะครับคราวหน้ากลับมานะครับพบกับ
น้องเรียนเกียติสาย 5 สอบวันนี้ขอบคุณมาก
ครับแล้วเดี๋ยวเขาหน้ากลับมาเจอกันวันนี้
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่า
เบียร์สวัสดีนักเรียนครับบ๊ายบาย